gracias
hola voy a empezar contándoles un
poquito de niñas con las que yo trabajo
este y de las cuales he tenido la
oportunidad de aprender mucho una de
ellas es blanca blanca tiene 11 años y
es la hija menor de 15 y de 15 hermanos
y su mamá de hecho tuvo más hijos pero
no se sabe muy bien qué pasó con esos
niños ellos solo dicen no vivo de 4 los
demás murieron no se sabe de que esté
pero ella es la menor de 15 su mamá tuvo
que venir de una comunidad rural a
trabajar a puebla trabaja en el comercio
informal y al igual que blanca no fue a
la escuela
ninguna de las dos y la la otra chica
con la que con la que trabajo se llama
fer fértil de 10 años es la hija más
pequeña de tres hermanos y a su mamá la
obligaron a adjuntarse a casarse cuando
tenía 14 años
se dedica a estar en su casa para
preparar la comida para su papá su mamá
y sus hermanos que salen a trabajar
todos los días les cuento esto porque
como ellas hay millones de niñas y niños
y adolescentes que no van a la escuela
que todos los días se quedan a trabajar
o salen a trabajar o se quedan en su
casa este y no tienen la posibilidad de
aprender a leer y escribir baile tengo
que ir pasando disculpen ustedes
este
ya me pase
no tienen la posibilidad de aprender a
leer y escribir imagínense lo que es
crecer en una ciudad como pueblo sin
saber leer y escribir sin saber
matemáticas y teniendo que enfrentar la
vida así como ellas hay muchos millones
de niños y niñas en este país que no que
no van a la escuela
y no van a la escuela porque existe una
gran desigualdad de oportunidades para
que todos podamos tener acceso a las
mismas cosas de hecho méxico es un país
con muy baja movilidad social lo que
significa que no es tanto el esfuerzo
que hagas o el talento que tengas lo que
va a llevarte a moverte a cambiar tus
condiciones de vida sino tiene que ver
con la familia donde naciste hay un
estudio muy que acaba de salir del
centro de estudios espinosa yglesias de
movilidad social donde dice esto 74 2 de
cada 100 mexicanos que nacen en lugares
pobres
a vivir en hogares pobres durante toda
su vida adulta cosa que de por sí ya es
difícil de aceptar no y de entender pero
además de estos de estos hogares pobres
si eres niña tienes aún menores
probabilidades de cambiar tus
condiciones de vida y otro dato que me
parece que es muy para reflexionar es si
además tu tono de piel es más oscuro
tienes menos posibilidades de cambiar tu
es cuando tu nivel socioeconómico que si
tu tono de piel es claro a veces es muy
importante que lo pensemos porque este
hay muchas personas en méxico que viven
en esta situación y además somos
mexicanos y nuestro tono de piel pues es
oscuro como este y entonces estas niñas
niñas como blanca y ferb pues no no no
fueron a la escuela son niñas y tienen
un tono de piel oscuro y entonces
imaginemos su futuro imagina
si las condiciones en las que ellas van
a vivir serán muy distintas a las que
vivieron sus mamás
y sus familias y esta situación la viven
los millones de niños y niñas es difícil
romper ese ciclo de pobreza
ese ciclo de violencia en el que viven
de negligencia de abandono etcétera
-este y bueno para terminar ese dato
para algunos para que algunos se alivian
lo mismo pasa en el sentido contrario
las personas que viven en familias de un
nivel socioeconómico alto es difícil que
su nivel socioeconómico bajo y con y
siendo adultos vivirán en una familia
con un nivel socioeconómico alto pero es
más probable que una mujer de un nivel
socioeconómico alto baje su nivel
socioeconómico a que lo haga un hombre
no son algunos datos que me parece que
es importante que podamos reflexionar y
que tiene que ver con estas poblaciones
con las que nosotros estamos trabajando
entonces desde la web
creemos y estamos convencidos de que el
motor de la transformación es mucho la
educación justo uno de los problemas por
los cuales méxico es un país este que
tiene muy poca movilidad social es la
educación no solo porque hay todavía
educación que tiene muchas deficiencias
sino porque como les decía todavía hay
muchos niños niñas y jóvenes que no
pueden asistir a la escuela no y
entonces nosotros estamos trabajando
justamente por la educación el trabajo
que hacemos desde la uap y
particularmente desde el centro
universitario de participación social
lo voy a lograr este tiene que ver con
cómo a partir de la educación buscamos
transformar esas realidades
trabajamos con esta población estos son
datos muy fríos pero si si pensamos que
hay más o menos 5 millones de niños y
niñas fuera de la escuela y tiene una
ciudad como puebla hay aproximadamente
30.000 niños niñas y jóvenes fuera de la
escuela pues tenemos mucho trabajo que
hacer porque si tenemos una rueda de la
fortuna muy linda pero también tenemos
estas otras realidades y es importante
que las volvemos a ver porque muchas
veces no se ven no y entonces creemos en
los datos que nos dicen la educación es
universal es gratuita etcétera etcétera
pero aún méxico no se mueve y no se va a
mover solo con los gobiernos necesitamos
que se mueva con las manos de todos
nosotros estamos trabajando ahora entre
otros programas que hacemos en la web
con un programa que se llama escuelas
comunitarias aprendiendo para la vida
donde buscamos
que estas niñas y estos niños tengan
espacio para aprender y para aprender
matemáticas sí para aprender ciencias y
para aprender a leer y escribir pero
algo muy importante es para aprender a
convivir para aprender a relacionarse
con otros en igualdad de condiciones
aprender a conocerse y aprender a decir
sí o aprender a decir no a aprender que
son personas que valen y que tienen
muchas posibilidades de ir logrando
pequeñas cosas es difícil decirle si vas
a ser doctora como quieres o si vas a
hacer paleontólogo como quieres pero si
vamos trabajando constantemente con
ellos lograremos que puedan aprender y
que puedan de alguna forma pues cambiar
ese futuro que tenían deparado desde que
nacieron ese futuro que ya traían desde
que desde que su mamá le decidió o no
decidió tenerlas entonces este
trabajamos todos los días con niños
niñas y adolescentes de entre 4 y 16
años en colonias de la periferia del
municipio
y es un trabajo en donde se aprende
mucho donde los niños y las niñas tienen
mucho que decir y mucho que dar y
también donde nos damos cuenta que si no
trabajamos con ellos que si no los
volteamos a ver esa realidad un día se
nos va a salir de las manos a todos y
estamos convencidos de que quienes
tuvimos el derecho que es la educación
tenemos la responsabilidad de trabajar
con quienes no lo han tenido eso eso es
muy importante para nosotros
tendremos la responsabilidad de
participar para que las condiciones
cambien no sólo de estas poblaciones
sino de todos participar y ahí me parece
muy importante decirlo en todos nuestros
programas funcionan con voluntarios con
estudiantes de servicio social pero
sobre todo con las voluntades de todos
los que decidimos y creemos en la
educación y queremos participar
participar para transformar porque hay
quien entiende la participación y se los
digo porque ya nos ha pasado mucho este
como donaron una muñeca sin brazos no o
un peluche muros o hay quien entiende
este la participación cada vez que se
oye colecta a una colecta pues me
deshago de toda mi ropa vieja no nos
pasó en el volcán con las casas
afectadas por el sismo que nos llegaron
vestidos de novia trajes de baño y uno
dice aquí se le ocurrió que las personas
iban a decidir casarse ahora no hubiera
nada no se trata de deshacerse de cosas
eso no es participar
eso no es participar participar si puede
ser darle un click a algo que me gusta o
compartir una información pero no
necesariamente el activismo online
resuelve participar no es hacer
altruismo y suponer que soy muy buena
onda y me voy a ganar una estatua porque
regale lo que ya no me servía participar
para transformar es voltear a ver esa
realidad que tenemos es reflexionar en
torno a eso que está pasando y que no
está pasando en mi casa pero que les
decía hace rato porque puede llegar a
pasar a mi casa porque si si esos niños
no tienen otras oportunidades que van a
hacer cuando necesiten comer no y esas
realidades van a llegar a nuestra casa
entonces nos parece muy importante que
pensemos en eso hay que hay que observar
y hay que reflexionar esas realidades
que a todos nos conciernen y queremos
invitar sobre todo a la comunidad
universitaria pero a todos a participar
para transformarlas porque en esa
participación no sólo vamos a aportar y
no solo vamos a buscar cambiar también
vamos a aprender
también nos vamos a transformar a
nosotros porque esas personas también
tienen mucho que decir
cierro con una cosa que una frase que
dice paulo freire la educación no no va
a cambiar el mundo pero sí va a cambiar
a las personas que van a cambiar el
mundo y estas somos todos nosotros
porque si tuvimos educación entonces los
invito a eso a participar para
transformar y para transformarnos muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]